when Scorsese came out and he said I
don't think these superhero movies are
Cinema I don't know where you stand with
that I'm curious he's an old man you
think Scorsese is going to be into
Ant-Man versus the WASP why not but he's
not going to be all right I don't I
don't think he would have been that into
that at 37 forget about how [ __ ] old
he is now I mean I used to collect
Marvel comic books yeah if all this [ __ ]
was coming out in 86 I would be all down
with it you know they waited till I got
too old I mean I ended up talking to a
kid just at a at a party the other day
if you're listening Brandon I'm talking
about you and he started a conversation
with me he asked me about what I felt
about superhero movies and I know this
kid is like I don't know how old he is
16 or 17. he's talking about how he saw
the first Iron Man when he was four to
him Marvel movies and DC movies are
movies and there's been actually almost
no competition to show him that there
can be anything else and if it's not
that it's Star Wars movies and if it's
not that it's the Harry Potter movie